歡迎回到趙花
我們今天要好好來幫大家聊
就是談到這邊不是回檔了嗎
對呀
其實是不是滿地都是機會
唉唷
是不是啊
這個等下來賓會說
為什麼都給來賓
因為等下給來賓發揮啊
因為以技術形態來說
有時候反而是
你一波談上去找不到什麼切入點
沒錯
可是一旦回檔切入點就變得很多了
我們現在歡迎接來賓
因為大家都非常的喜歡他
也非常的熟悉
我也很喜歡 不要講
給你
好 接下來的是我們的
K線之神 朱家宏 朱老師
大家好 大家好
好 朱老師 我們來聊一下
因為之前一直在談嘛
台股要不要打腳啊什麼的
好像真的打了
打了反而是好事喔
那今天要來教我們什麼呢
因為打了就可能出現
所謂的轉折
對不對
如果懂轉折的人
其實上面下來也能轉
下面上去也能
怎麼那麼厲害
對啊
對
我也加入你們的門派了
今天二對一
好 朱老師先幫我們看這個多頭驅使
我們最後給一個問
好 這個
我們看我們的大盤
那昨天是不是有轉折了
因為他上去下來了嘛
那這個就轉折了
所以昨天出現轉折
昨天出現轉折
那如果你是下面轉折買的
那上面呢 要賣了嘛
只要你出現轉折
如果你下面買這個強反彈嘛
那你現在疊你就賣掉了
就這麼一例嗎
一例啊 如果你做空也看
你出現轉折空
然後這邊出現轉折就補
你這邊空 這邊補
這邊空 這邊補嘛
就這樣子 做空啦
做空
那你強反彈當然在下面搶嘛
那下面是不是一個轉折
那這裡是不是一個轉折
所以你在轉折的地方買
在轉折的地方買就結束了
是
那我們的大盤呢
再來看趨勢
我們的大盤在反彈的時候
已經過了這個前高了
對
那現在它不是空頭
也不是多頭
它有頭頭高
這邊是底底
所以還差了一個底底高
那這邊我們就在等這個
又是等一個轉折
那這個轉折如果一出現
他就變成多頭了
多頭是做多
所以就可以做多了
如果下次轉折
因為我們做股票計幅分析的人
不是在說明天我叫做
而是明天出現轉折我才做
你沒有出現
也許還會再下來
那下來這邊
也是會看到一個轉折
如果符合這樣子的話
他也是一個多頭架構
所以我們的大盤基本上來講
現在應該算是強勢反彈之後
就在等第二支腳了
那第二支腳的先結條件
要先回來嘛
如果你這邊不回來
就沒有第二支腳啊
所以在沒有回來的時候
大家都講說他不會回來
每次股票也是
連續漲五六天
大家都都不會回來了
那實際上歷史證明嗎
他一定會回來
好 那我們現在等到回來
那現在就在等上漲
等這個轉折
如果等到了大盤就轉多
那當然不是每個人都在做大盤嘛
那你就股票就同理可證
用同樣的方法去證明你的股票就可以了
好 因為呢 鍾老師跟艾倫
對不對 都是看技術型態的
但因為我自己會去看基本面
事實上台股基本面很好
例如說營收創新高
然後還有就是所謂的第二季季報
可能三律 三生也都創立新高
但是這樣的股票是不是一定可以買
可能要輔助於技術型態的檢驗
對 這就是我們講說
基本面好 營收好
各種利多消息的股票
會出現一大堆
絕對不會只有一檔
可是這麼多股票裡面
你要選到這個能夠會漲的股票
那這個時候技術面就很重要
比如說我們來看一下
這個營收創新高的 非常多
我來解釋一下這張表
這張表是融合了第二季的季報
跟七月營收
全部的項目通通創新高
就是很厲害的股票
就是 台股在基本面上
無可挑剔的一群人
可是可以看到他們的股價
卻是一個撐刺不起的狀態
會差很遠
有的還是空投
對 那我們都講說
營收好也不是說
今天發佈才知道營收好
應該在他前面
至少公司派知道
我這個月結算 營收會很好
可是很奇怪
他的股價還是會跌
對不對
所以他不是一個絕對的關係
不是說我營收好
我的股價就絕對漲
不是的
那可是我們做股票是在賺價差
如果你不漲
你營收好對我沒用
你又不會把賺的錢給我
我要買到你股票
股票漲我才會賺到錢
所以我們要在這裡面
就要去過濾一下
哪些是真的有了營收
而且又有技術面
那這樣子我們做股票是不是就比較容易賺到錢
就不會因為營收就亂買
那你可能還會賠錢
這邊的話分散在各領域
像成熟製程 PC
這個很有名啊 聯電
大量這個很戲劇性
昨天漲停 今天接聽
金居這好多人喜歡
齊宏 CPO 的光盛聯亞
設備股的萬潤雅翔
記憶體的創建位
都是指標類的股票
都是算是檯面上
大家都認得的股票
對不對 都知道這些股票
可是越是認得的越要小心
因為你很熟悉它嘛
那你一定會覺得它很好
比如像京居
大概沒有人不知道這支股票
因為他前一陣子實在太有名了
他就是長這樣削掉
踢台的第一棒 對不對
可是你看它跌下來不是跌混了
全部都給你跌掉一半以上
那我們最重要的說
大盤現在既然不跌了
是不是我們這些跌的股票
都可以買了
那我還有這個 還有營收啊
對啊 還是不一定
還有機報 對
所以我們還是要稍微的去看一下
那我今天在這邊
最主要就給大家一個
很簡單的操作的一個邏輯
因為技術分析真的說起來
內容也是滿多的啦
但是一般的觀眾
我用最簡單的方法
讓你能夠很快的就抓到股票
又能夠賺到錢
那這個方法其實就兩句話
這叫趨勢 第二個加轉折
所以你要先認好趨勢
然後再去抓他的轉折
所以我如果大家習慣做多頭股票
所以這支股票
一定要先多頭確認
好 要先確認
在這個確認之前
你都不要去買他
因為你是做多
所以趨勢要多
那現在趨勢確認了
我就開始抓轉折
那這個是上漲下跌
那我做多不可能做下跌
所以你一定是坐在這裡嘛
下跌然後上漲嘛
沒錯
對不對
而且底不能破錢低嘛
我就講多頭趨勢一定要維持
要維持
只要它在多頭的裡面
你在轉折的低點買
在轉折的高點賣
所以我這邊有幾句話
你記下就好了
轉折向上買
突破盤子買
轉折向下賣
怎麼覺得我也會了
你會他
但你要土打開 我就不一定了
不是 大家其實比較做錯
就是因為趨勢沒有把它辨別出來
你沒有看懂這個趨勢
只要你看懂它是多頭就這麼要
轉折向上買 轉折向下賣
就這賣 然後你要看懂趨勢
這個不是多 它盤整
所以你後面就不能買了
如果你在盤子裡面轉折賣
然後你就一巴來巴去
很容易雙巴
對 你就被扒了嘛
所以我當我趨勢看懂了
我的第二句話 突破盤整買
那我又等到你突破
所以突破盤整你買
那從那什麼時候賣
轉折向下賣
轉折向上賣
你只要這個沒有變
你就一直做一直做一直做
那他又進到盤整了
我還是賣掉了嘛
因為我轉折向下你要賣啊
所以你不會被套牢啊
朱老師如果他沒有進入盤整
他只是多頭回答
我不賣可以嗎
那就是這個
那就是做長線
那我今天提供大家說
在短線上
你其實用這樣子的觀念
你至少不會買錯
你不會買到高檔
你一定買在轉折
那你也知道在哪裡賣
也不會賣飛
因為你就轉折下來我才賣
那就簡單的這個原則
我相信你對你做股票
就有一個標準
有一個基本邏輯
對 基本的邏輯
你不會亂買 你又不會亂賣
買在相對的低點
賣在相對的高點
你這樣子的先有了這個邏輯
反過來說
因為我們也有看到
觀眾朋友留言說
你們都在教人家做多
如果高檔下來
怎麼不交做空呢
我就想說
其實就圖反過來
應該就反過來
對 空頭的股票
他已經確認
空頭確認
跌低低投投低
我現在開始你要做空嘛
做空就反過來
再轉折向下賣
轉折向上補
我們空頭要回補啦
轉折向下空 轉折向上補
然後還要不要向下空
盤整的時候先不要
就不要了嘛
因為它不是空頭
重點就是它不是空頭
然後這邊又跌破了
盤整跌破空
你就補空 補空
一直補到
又補到這個底底高了
那你又不做了
那你不做
如果它不下去了
它上來了你也不會做了
因為它轉成多頭了嘛
你就不會做
所以至少你不會做錯
不會做錯方向
不會做錯原則
這是最基本的嘛
你這樣子
剛剛我們的標的
第一頁就講
你就不會被套牢啊
你只要按到做你就不會套牢
你是賺錢的
你不會賠錢的
只是你有時候運氣好
他一直跌 你就多賺一點嘛
尤其你做到後面
有可能就會極跌
那你這一段就賺了很多
所以我用這樣簡簡單的方法
你就像剛才趙花講
你又可以做多
你也可以做空啊
那只有一個不能做
就這個盤整
盤整區兩個都不要做
對 不管多空盤整都不要做
因為盤整我們不知道
未來是上起來還是下來
這是市場來決定的
所以我們就等
如果是空樓
市場把它又點破
那我們就繼續空
所以把握這兩個原則
我相信大家做股票
就會比較輕鬆
沒有說這麼複雜 這麼難
藍就說你要把趨勢先把它辨別出來
我覺得我已經記起來了
那觀眾朋友記起來了沒有呢
因為接下來我們要混搭一些圖
好 那這些圖呢
都是剛剛講到的
奇略元素創新高
第二季季報創新高的好股票
那現在我們先來看大量
這個是他的波動很大
大量波動
對 那股票剛才我們講
我們列出來都是財報很好的
但是不一定圖很好
另外一個原則就是說
我現在要做多是不是
所以你一定是在做未來嘛
你不會做到這一段多來嘛
那這一段都已經過了
也做不到
所以我們要做未來嘛
那未來我又不知道啊
所以你要用當下
這叫當下
就今天
今天收盤來判斷
這支股票到底是多還是空
今天跌停版
跌停版不一定是空中
還爆亮
也不一定
都不一定
趨勢歸趨勢 成交量歸成交量
均線歸均線
你就是一個多頭股票
有時候均線還是空排
它不一定是多排
是
好 那我們就看今天這根K線
是不是跌破5日均線
對
那是不是有個轉折了
跌破5日就算轉折了
就是本來昨天早今天跌
那不就是轉折了嗎
這麼嚴格
那換句話講
如果你有買的今天要賣
可是這橫盤都沒賺到錢
跌破五軍就要先走
那我們現在先看他的趨勢
那這裡一出轉折
是不是這邊就有一個高點
對
這裡就有一個高點
是
那上轍的轉折在哪裡
是不是這個紅K站上來
這裡有一個低點
對
觀眾應該看得到嘛
對不對
因為這個黑K是不是跌破五軍
紅K
然後黑K紅K是不是站上五軍
是
所以這裡就有一個低點
上轍的轉折
低點在這裡
這一次的高點已經在這裡了
再來上次的高點是不是在這裡
對嘛 因為它跌破了嘛
所以它上來 動又下來
所以這裡有個高點
那低點在這
好低
就最低嘛
好 那你先看這幾個點的關係是什麼
就是
這個頭 這個頭 這個底 這個底
是什麼
他這樣了
頭頭高 低高
他說多頭形態
這個頭頭高低低高啊
那既然是多頭
所以今天這個跌下來叫回檔
跌停板 但它是回檔
你不要亂空
你不要以為說
這麼弱的股票
它今天是多頭的回檔
那多頭回檔
我剛剛講
多頭倒不是可以做多
那什麼時候做
明天大漲的話
會後買上 轉折向上的時候買
轉折向上吧
轉折向上
你這個劇張就可以買了
那買了也好 什麼時候買
轉折向下你就買
這樣對不對
那明天要漲多少才能買呢
站上五軍啊
只要站上五軍都可以
這邊站上五軍
這邊就有低點
那如果我在考一下主持人好
他針對我
OK吧
誰跟你說明天會漲
那今天跌地板大量明天會跌
對不對
以這個K線來講明天是會跌的
沒錯
這是講K線
那如果明天跌
對
後天又跌
是
有轉折向上了
對不對
這邊轉折向上
那這邊轉折向上
那請問
這個人可不可以買
不行
為什麼
因為他一比一比低
多頭不是轉折向上來嘛
可是他已經打了一個
底啊又比前面的底低嘛
因為他跌
沒錯
他跌負了這個低點
對啊
對啊他變盤整了
你不能買的原因是
它不是多頭
是
我們第一個條件叫多頭
那不是多頭你就不能買了
是
這樣就很清楚了
對不對
那如果在
如果在月線這裡的轉折呢
可以
對
它就是轉折向上來
是
下次轉折向下
那轉折向下
也有幾個變化
比如說我到了月線
前面低點沒破
我在這裡
終於真的來了
我在這裡買了
對
那什麼時候就是轉折向下賣
那結果在這裡轉折向下
哇 要不要賣
他過的前面的高不用賣
過的前面高更要賣
賺更多了
賣
轉折向下要賣
那賣了以後
這邊又轉折向上
底底高要不要賣
這無間地獄
無間考題
沒有
你稍微打打 你技術分析就通
是
對吧
剛才我們的圖都有
因為我這個轉折向下
沒有過這個高點
所以這邊就不能買
因為它進到盤子
就下這盤子
你看技術分析
你未來的全部都規劃好了
請問這個股票有什麼不敢做
所以你不要怕
你往下我也知道
你往上我也知道
你不過高我也知道
我都有方法去做
這些是技術東西最好的地方
而且每個人都可以去規劃
那至於他怎麼走
就不是我們決定的
如果我決定就這樣子
這要最好 對不對
我先上車 你再決定
就市場他決定什麼我就做什麼
他走什麼就做什麼
所以這一支股票擺上來
再加上我們已經知道壓力機好了
那只要我做多我就放心做
那為什麼可能有這樣
因為這裡有大量
大家不是很擔心大量不過怎麼辦
那不過你就賣嘛
轉折向下你就賣嘛
你就不會有這麼多煩惱
對不對
考題一我已經背上都是漢語
考題二光盛
光盛也是
我上課的學生都沒講考官
我就一直講一直講
回去你聽得懂就懂
聽不懂就算
所以觀眾有福了
今天一起參加考試
對啦 好
一樣這又是一個業績很好的
而且光剩本來就是一支很好的股票
以前在CPU是領頭揚鑫的這部比較弱
所以基本面沒有問題
但是基本面沒有問題
如果你在這裡買你就完蛋
因為它是空頭
就很簡單
它就是空頭
你不要說空頭什麼
大量紅蝙蝠你就跑來買
空頭你做空鑽結
轉折下來空
上去補
下來空
你還是鑽結
我就一直跟大家講
你學會了
學會了 你就偷偷練一練
練完了你就有信心了
你下次就會自己做了
可是現在不是囉
因為我講我們做當下
當下來看
昨天黑K是跌下來了
是不是有轉折 對嘛
那是不是有高點了 有
所以高點這個很清楚啊
一看到了
這個是高點
那上次的低點呢
有往前推那個月線上的黑K
黑K跌破了五軍
紅K站上
所以這裡有個低點
然後高點在這
因為我講黑黑疊破了嘛
所以上面有個高點
最低點當然一看大家都知道
這1000塊
剛好卡在1000塊
1000塊這是最低點
那我們看到今天
你看到的頭跟底是什麼
頭頭高
低底高
多頭形態
跟剛才是不是一模一樣
現在如果你要做多頭要做多啦
那什麼時候做
不破錢低又上漲的時候
就轉折向上的時候
轉折向上
然後又沒有破錢低
那後面的走勢
就跟剛才考試是一樣
如果跌破錢低
你就不要買了
或者你在月線上來
那沒有過高
你轉折向下
你要買
這樣子
你這支做多的股票就已經痛了
對不對
那如果他真的這樣一直走
走到那個3000塊2500
那你就一直做
你就一直坐上去
那現在為什麼那麼多好機會
現在因為前面這些好股票
都跌得很深
當一個基本面好
然後財務也好
你本來就知道這些股票有價值了
這就叫有價值
那現在又有低價
那這個應該算是優先去把他選擇的
因為我們講跌的時候種植
類型沒有基本面的
現在不一定會上來
因為跌的大家都嚇死了
都不敢去買了
但是這些有基本面
又有技術面的
是我們優先可以去選
不過像剛剛如果大萊根光智
現在都多頭型態
有沒有誰比較好的問題
有沒有誰比較好的比較
因為可能很多都長這樣子
第一個我們講先要多頭
其實多頭你就可以做了
但你要加強說
我要做到更好的多頭
長得更快
速度更快
或是空間更大
對 那空間大就是看上面壓力
你的壓力還有成交量
那我現在這邊有量
我這個量已經過了
對不對
除非你又把它跌破了
那我這個量
你畫一條線
你就知道你大概會長到
是
畫到這邊
紅幫主老師接過來
老師老師接過來
所以至少先供到這
先供到這
2000塊
剛好一倍
剛好1000
那如果我在過程中再放量
那當然再去挑戰這個
2千3
是
這個就是你可以做比較
基本的規劃
那另外還有一個
因為我們大部分都是
底部鋼管完成多的
所以還有些你不要去做
就是均線還沒有做
那這是為什麼那麼好
這是均線做好了
月線上揚
月線已經上揚
月線是最基本的
只要你月線上揚
你就可以去做了
那你如果從學會問
老師那個季線壓了怎麼辦
對
那你把剛才的優望
你記線壓了
轉折向下你就賣
你就賣了
你不會說
記線壓了我就一直賠一直賠
所以我們剛才那個原則
就是大家把它寄勞
所有的問題你都不要怕
只要你不要做錯方向
你不要說空頭去做多
這個麻煩了對不對
只要你是把趨勢加上轉折
你在股票市場可以說是無往不利
聯電
那聯電也是大家你看前面怎麼漲的
對不對
大家暴雨後望
想說這下要230
那一樣大盤不好他就回來了
可是他財報還是很好啊
還是很好 上新高
所以大家就會懷疑
他為什麼會點那麼多呢 對不對
財報就像財機店
這個業績他不要點那麼多
可是股票本來就不是我們
可以自己去想的
我們完全根據他
那我們就來看這支股票紅了
它就不一樣了
這支股票不是昨天
前三天就跌破五軍
所以他前天一跌破五軍
你的高點就出來了對不對
這個黑黑跌破嘛
高點就出來了嘛
那前面的低點在哪裡
紅可以站上嘛對不對
所以這是不是低點
是
那他跌破這個站上
這個黑黑所以這你是高點
那這你是低點
對不對 對
那這個這個是頭頭高
這個是底底高
這是多頭
但是今天我們把它看一下
因為很接近這個價格
沒有啦 今天已經把這個底點跌破
他把它跌破了
所以今天他就不是多頭了
所以這支股票你就不能說
轉折向上來買
因為他不是多頭了
要嗎 還有一個就我剛剛講的
這個月線還很糟糕
我下彎的很厲害
還在壓嘛
所以你就
就算他這個很好
請你擺在後面去
因為我們剛剛那兩隻已經很棒了
那兩隻比較好
對啊 你就說了嘛
就是我們講說
剛才趙豪問的
那到底要做哪一隻啊
哪個比較好啊
哪個比較強啊
那聯電你就暫時不要去做他
因為剛才那一隻也是100多嘛
那這也是100多嘛
剛剛那隻是1000多老師
沒有 還有一隻100多吧
兩隻都比較高價
兩支都很高價
好嗎
那你就等這一輩
所以大家為什麼散戶朋友
特別獨一的價格比較親密
對
你就等他
等他符合我們的條件
好 那我們還是一樣
再來看
亞翔
我們設備股的那個龍頭
亞翔當然我們一看就知道
因為這邊就一路往下
對不對
這個頭啊
頭啊 頭啊
越來越破低
可是所以我們現在就剛剛講
這是最低點
那這個黑黑疊下來 這是高疊
那現在疊下來還沒有上去啊
對
那它前面的高疊在哪
在這啊
對
對不對 這個疊下來嘛
所以它還在頭頭疊啊
那這個低點的前面在這啊
這叫底底底
所以它叫空頭的彈後空下疊
它還完全沒有做成多頭
沒有 它是空的
那你做空不是疊下來做空嗎
所以你其實在這裡做空
是
來 你做空這幾天
你賺錢了耶
也賺錢
我捨不得空亞翔
真的
而且他越線還在向下
對不對
那如果他繼續空
有可能還要這個底
不過這個股票
大概你不會空到太多了
因為這個底就是一個微型反轉
而且這邊有大量
對 所以大家就要注意
你如果做空要什麼時候補
轉折的時候補
轉折向上
回答得很心虛
轉折向補啦
那你如果轉折向上補
你沒有賠錢啊
那有什麼好害怕的
我只要一上上我就補啊
我又不能有賠錢
我沒這個問題
因為我不會空牙箱
然後你補了以後
假設在這裡
哇從這裡到這裡你賺錢
然後它又疊了
叫胃控
可以
為什麼
因為他還沒有做好多頭
你轉著一上這個就要叫底底高
兩個底做好了
對 他見盤子
他見到盤子你覺得
所以你就等一等
這次盤子有可能就變多了
考試不通過
你後面再變多
這樣好不好
所以我們今天就用簡單的這幾個
邏輯了
大家至少拉出一支股票
你就按照這樣去
比手畫腳
你就知道可以做還是不能做
我們散戶就只要知道這個
就可以了嘛
我知道可以做 知道不能做
你就可以避開很多的風險
我今天只有一個慶幸
就是這個螢幕是有邊框的
所以畫到後面
我不用再回答了
對 但是我今天很遺憾
是我的小老師都沒有要幫我
我認真看
所以今天也很謝謝朱老師
每一次朱老師都講得簡潔易懂
可是等到看到圖的時候
我們就會產生猶豫了
因為很久以前我就上過做老師的課
可以說繼續看
所以今天我們花了一點時間
即使是簡單的口訣
不管做多或做空
搭配圖大家回家練習一下
對
好